y
[Música]
el gobierno de finlandia aprobó
formalmente solicitar el ingreso del
país a la otan la decisión debe ser
ratificada por el parlamento y podría
poner fin a casi ocho décadas de
neutralidad militar de esta nación algo
que el kremlin ha advertido sería un
error la primera ministra de suecia
también aprobó presentar la candidatura
de su país
en medio de un profundo descontento
social y con pocas expectativas de
cambio el líbano votó para renovar el
parlamento se trata de los primeros
comicios legislativos desde el gran
estallido de 2019 el ex primer ministro
saad hariri llamó a boicotear la jornada
en eeuu al menos 10 personas perdieron
la vida y otras tres resultaron heridas
en un tiroteo perpetrado por un
supremacista en la localidad de buffalo
en nueva york' las autoridades
informaron que el hombre portaba
equipamiento militar y transmitió en
vivo el ataque los hechos son
investigados como un posible crimen de
odio
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos esta emisión en
finlandia donde el gobierno anunció su
decisión formal de buscar su adhesión a
la otan el anuncio lo dieron el
presidente del país raúl y ministro y la
primera ministra sana marín en una
conferencia de prensa conjunta ahora
seguirá un proceso parlamentario para
formalizar la solicitud con esta medida
helsinki abandona la política de
neutralidad que mantuvo durante años
desde el fin de la segunda guerra
mundial finlandia comparte más de 1.300
kilómetros de largo con rusia quien
advirtió de consecuencias en caso de
adhesión al bloque atlántico más en la
siguiente historia
hace meses era solo una perspectiva
lejana hoy finlandia rompió con décadas
de no alineamiento militar cuando
anunció oficialmente que quiere unirse a
la otan un giro provocado por la
invasión rusa ucrania
hoy el presidente de la república y el
comité de política exterior del gobierno
han acordado conjuntamente que finlandia
solicitará el ingreso en la otan pero es
contra cotto a la que ya se está previa
consulta el parlamento calesita nos han
pasado muchas cosas de la última vez que
nos reunimos aquí el 24 de febrero si
este es un día histórico se abre una
nueva era
un camino que suecia también quiere
seguir el jefe de la otan james
totenberg dijo que los dos países serán
recibidos con los brazos abiertos
finlandeses que son los socios más
cercanos de la otan su ingreso en la
otan aumentaría nuestra seguridad
compartida y demostraría que la puerta
de la otan está abierta
nate tu sur y sobre el apoyo a la
adhesión a la otan ha aumentado
drásticamente en ambos países
todos los miembros de la alianza quieren
poner fin a esta guerra lo antes posible
pero estamos igualmente decididos a
mantener nuestra asistencia de seguridad
de ucrania continuar con nuestras
acciones controles de exportación y
presión diplomática sobre rusia mientras
rusia sigue con su guerra el ingreso de
finlandia y suecia en lo tan es
exactamente el tipo de movimiento que
moscú quería evitar cuando comenzó su
ofensiva
advirtió de las graves consecuencias
como la amenaza de desplegar armas
nucleares en kaliningrado este
territorio ruso está ubicado entre
polonia y lituania miembros de la otan
europea
entre tanto magdalena anderson la
primera ministra de la vecina suecia
informó también en rueda de prensa que
su país pedirá la adhesión a la otan y
que irá al parlamento el lunes para
asegurar un amplio apoyo a la solicitud
de ingreso anderson aseguró que suecia
necesita las garantías de seguridad
formal que vienen asociadas a la alianza
atlántica y reconoció que durante el
proceso suecia se puede ver en una
situación vulnerable pese a todo
apostilló que este cambio de guión en la
política sueca no supone dejar de
apostar por el desarme nuclear a nivel
mundial
nosotros los socialdemócratas creemos
que lo mejor para la seguridad de suecia
y del pueblo sueco es que nos unamos al
otan esta es una decisión que fue tomada
después de cuidadosas deliberaciones
para nosotros los socialdemócratas es
claro que la no alineación militar ha
servido bien a suecia pero nuestra
conclusión es que no nos servirán
también en el futuro
si seguimos en ucrania la ofensiva de
las tropas rusas continua centrada en la
región del donbass el ejército ucraniano
reconoció avances de los soldados rusos
al tiempo informó que emprendió una
contraofensiva en las cercanías de la
estratégica ciudad de acción en la
región de jarquín al otro lado del país
en el bid cerca de la frontera con
polonia un ataque ruso con los misiles
destruyó infraestructura militar
y la seguridad alimentaria de millones
de personas está en riesgo como producto
de la invasión de rusia a ucrania y de
las intensas sequías en diversos países
del planeta la oficina de las naciones
unidas para la agricultura y la
alimentación advirtió que podría
avecinarse hambre desnutrición protestas
flujos migratorios y tensiones
geopolíticas en diversos países
se aproxima una crisis alimentaria
mundial el conflicto entre rusia y
ucrania quienes representan casi un
tercio del trigo y la cebada del planeta
ha disparado los precios de los
alimentos sumándose a una crisis
energética que impacta a los sistemas de
distribución francés
tal vez en polonia y bulgaria que gastan
una mayor parte de sus ingresos en
alimentos estarán mucho más afectados
por los precios más caros el sur de
europa áfrica egipto y los países árabes
también son grandes importadores de
cereales es posible que se enfrenten a
faltas de suministro y precios más altos
estos países realmente sufrirán el
mercado de alimentos ya venía en crisis
entre otras cosas por la pandemia de
kobe 19 además en frente a la intensa
sequía que afecta a países como francia
eeuu canadá y la india este último tomó
la determinación de prohibir sus
exportaciones de trigo por sentir su
propia seguridad alimentaria amenazada
los ministros de agricultura del g7
rechazaron la decisión y la prohibición
afecta a países como bangladesh y nepal
que necesitan el trigo con urgencia los
jefes de estado y de gobierno del g7
deberán tomar una decisión concreta
sobre este tema y hacemos un llamado a
la línea para que asuma sus
responsabilidades como miembro del g-20
pero la india no es la única nación que
está respondiendo a la crisis con
proteccionismo una veintena de países ha
colocado medidas restrictivas de
exportaciones
ante esta situación el temor es que
millones de personas y ciudades podrían
ver a corto plazo hambre desnutrición
protestas flujos migratorios y tensiones
geopolíticas los representantes del
banco mundial el fondo monetario
internacional la organización mundial de
comercio y el programa mundial de
alimentos han llamado a realizar
acciones coordinadas de suministro de
alimentos de emergencia soporte
financiero y comercio abierto para
apoyar a las naciones más vulnerables
y el sábado por la noche el grupo k
loose orchestra representante de ucrania
se convirtió en el ganador del concurso
de eurovisión 2022 en medio de la guerra
con rusia tanto el grupo ganador como el
presidente volodymyr selenski
aprovecharon la ocasión para recordar al
mundo que ucrania todavía necesita ayuda
internacional
[Aplausos]
como un soplo de aire fresco para los
ciudadanos ucranianos sumidos en guerra
con rusia así se celebró la victoria del
grupo la lucha orchestra en el concurso
de eurovisión de este año en la ciudad
italiana de turín cada pequeña victoria
es importante para cada ucraniano para
nuestra ucrania para cada uno de
nosotros los ucranianos lograron ganar
con una canción que fusiona el rap con
la música folklórica
[Música]
dedicada a la madre del vocalista del
grupo y es que el asedio que está
sufriendo ucrania la convirtió en la
clara favorita de esta edición con un
récord de votación del público a su
favor y felicitaciones por parte de la
comunidad internacional y otros
organismos como la otan
we need your decision context me
gustaría felicitar a ucrania por haber
ganado el concurso de eurovisión y no lo
hago a la ligera porque ayer vimos el
inmenso apoyo del público en toda europa
y australia
tradicionalmente los ganadores acogen el
certamen el año siguiente algo que
ucrania espera poder hacer en 2023 con
la esperanza de haber dejado atrás el
conflicto con rusia
nuestro valor impresiona el mundo
nuestra música conquista europa el año
que viene ucrania acogerá el concurso de
eurovisión haremos todo lo posible para
que un día los participantes e invitados
de eurovisión sean recibidos en una
mariupol libre pacífica y reconstruida
no obstante en medio de las
celebraciones tanto el grupo musical
ganador como los políticos ucranianos
aprovecharon para mandar un mensaje
ucrania todavía necesita toda la ayuda
que se le pueda brindar
marín
[Aplausos]
e inició el conteo de los votos tras el
cierre de las urnas en el líbano el país
celebró los primeros comicios
legislativos desde el estallido social
de 2019 y mientras continúa ha sumido en
la peor crisis económica de su historia
desde beirut & el bonet corresponsal de
france 24 habló con algunos de los
ciudadanos sobre sus expectativas en
esta jornada que estuvo marcada por el
abstencionismo
estamos en itagüí un barrio de clase
media libanesa cristiana y uno de los
más afectados por la explosión del
puerto de agosto 2020 hasta ahora este
barrio ha sido feudo de las falanges
libanesas y también de las fuerzas
libanesas cristianas pero ahora los
partidos tradicionales compiten con
nuevas caras gente que ha salido de la
sociedad civil del descontento por la
crisis económica tan profunda que
atraviesa este país los partidos
tradicionales por supuesto que han
hablado de ayudar a cambiar la economía
pero no han dicho nada sobre la
corrupción y el clientelismo político
vamos a ver qué opinan los libaneses y
qué futuro creen que tiene este país
soy una persona positiva y quedamos muy
pocos en el país que tenemos esperanza
las elecciones son buenas para el cambio
y nuestros políticos se han dado cuenta
que tienen que cambiar confío en que las
cosas van a ir mejor después de las
elecciones de hoy tendrá seriamente
clave lo hasta
vivimos una de las peores crisis
económicas del mundo no podemos seguir
así es demasiado
vale nada me lo veis vez no es un error
no votar porque de lo contrario será aún
peor falla necesaria
con la crisis económica como mayor
preocupación los libaneses piden un
cambio más allá de un cambio democrático
lo que esperan es sanar su economía algo
que muchos han dejado de creer en sus
políticos tradicionales pero la
alternativa de los nuevos candidatos
también es complicado ya que son la
mayoría desconocidos y tampoco han
sabido dar alternativas para mejorar la
economía y hay tensión en israel cuando
se conmemora el aniversario número 74 de
la nakba día en que los palestinos y
árabes israelíes marcan la denominada
catástrofe que supuso la fundación del
estado de israel en 1948 cerca de
800.000 palestinos fueron desplazados de
sus hogares en aquel entonces y muchos
mantienen las esperanzas de regresar
esta conmemoración se registra tras
semanas de atentados y operaciones de
contraterrorismo del ejército israelí en
la cisjordania ocupada como respuesta
que han dejado decenas de muertos yanira
gómez muñoz corresponsal de france 24
jerusalén no es amplio
como cada 15 de mayo y los palestinos
recuerdan como en 1948 fueron expulsados
de sus tierras tras la guerra
árabe-israelí y la creación del estado
de israel entonces 700.000 personas
fueron forzadas al exilio y a
convertirse en desplazados sin embargo
esta nakba o catástrofe continúa para
5.7 millones de refugiados palestinos
según la onu que están repartidos entre
gaza cisjordania jordania líbano y siria
mientras el acto principal se centra en
ramala aquí en la ciudad vieja de
jerusalén este 74 aniversario se vive
con tensión empezando por los ingresos
de judíos a la explanada de las
mezquitas algo que ha reforzado la
arenga de hamás a defender al aqsa de la
ocupación israelí citando al portavoz
del grupo el asesinato de la periodista
palestino estadounidenses irina bua que
hace cuatro días y el ataque a su
funeral avivan está nakba sobre todo
cuando la policía israelí ha afirmado
que no habrá acciones disciplinarias
contra los oficiales que reprimieron el
cortejo fúnebre sobre esto y mientras
las investigaciones prosiguen el primer
ministro israelí naftalí bennett
prometió que las fuerzas israelí y
seguirán su campaña contra el terrorismo
sin mencionar a bucle a este contexto se
suma que sólo esta semana israel aprobó
4.000 nuevas viviendas en asentamientos
en cisjordania ocupada y que comenzaron
los desalojos en las poblaciones de
massaguer ya está en el sur de hebrón
donde unos 1.300 palestinos corren
riesgo de ser expulsados
y al menos diez personas murieron y tres
resultaron gravemente heridas después de
que un hombre armado en la ciudad de
buffalo en nueva york' abriera fuego en
un supermercado situado en un barrio
predominantemente afro el sábado en la
noche la mayoría de las víctimas eran
negras y se cree que el atacante tenía
ideas supremacistas la vicepresidenta
kamala harris aseguró que eeuu está
viviendo una epidemia de odio que
provoca daños contra todo el país el
periodista edgar costa desde el terreno
nos da más información
consternación en búfalo por una matanza
en un supermercado que ha tenido lugar
en un barrio de mayoría afroamericana
eso demuestra los objetivos de un
sospechoso que además tenía toda una
trayectoria en internet y es por eso que
hemos escuchado palabras de la
gobernadora del estado de nueva york-
del alcalde de buffalo contundentes no
sólo con el tema de las armas un
problema endémico en eeuu por que
repetidas veces tenemos que
lamentablemente informar de este tipo de
matanzas de terrorismo doméstico pero
está motivado en este caso por una
cuestión racial por una cuestión de
supremacía blanca que en internet se
alienta y es por eso que los oficiales
electos han hecho mucha insistencia en
las necesidades de trabajar en
legislaciones que permitan que esto no
vuelva a suceder
continúen conectados a france 24
[Música]